einen schönen guten Tag und herzlich
willkommen liebe Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer nach russischen Angaben hat
die ukrainische Armee eine Brücke zur
von Russland annektierten Halbinsel Krim
mit Raketen angegriffen die schon
H-Brücke verbindet also die Krim mit der
Region herson und soll demnach
beschädigt worden sein darüber sprechen
wir mit dem ehemaligen Staatssekretär im
Verteidigungsministerium Nico lange der
auch viele Jahre in Russland und in der
Ukraine tätig war guten Tag Herr Lange
hallo
guten Tag sollte also tatsächlich die
Ukraine hinter diesem Angriff stecken
wie würde sich dieser in die derzeit
laufende gegen Offensive der
ukrainischen Armee einfügen
die Ukraine war ja im Verlauf dieses
Krieges bisher ganz gut darin immer
wieder die Logistik der russischen Seite
zu schwächen und die wenigen Zugänge die
es zur Halbinsel Krim gibt gehören ganz
sicher zu diesen logistischen Arterien
und wenn der Ukraine ist gelingt die
Eisenbahnlinien die Brücken der
russischen Seite nicht mehr zugänglich
zu machen dann werden die Truppen
Probleme kriegen mit dem Nachschub bei
Munition bei Treibstoff das hat schon im
Norden von Kiew zum Erfolg geführt das
hat auch bei chrison zum Erfolg geführt
und mir scheint die Ukraine versuchen
jetzt eine ähnliche Vorgehensweise damit
sprechen sie im Prinzip schon die
strategische Bedeutung dieser Brücke an
wir können das vielleicht auch auf der
Karte uns noch mal angucken es gibt ja
noch weitere Brücken und Anfahrtswege
die die Krim mit der Ukraine und auch
mit dem russischen Festland sogar
verbinden die kerlbrücke in dem Fall
warum jetzt also wohl der Angriff auf
die schon hat Brücke
die Truppen der Ukraine greifen ja vor
allen Dingen im Süden an und der
Nachschub für diese Truppen im Süden
kommt ja sehr stark von der Krim aus
also gibt es eine Eisenbahnlinie die von
der Krim über Gengar in Richtung
milotopol verläuft und dann weiter die
russischen Truppen dort zum Beispiel
versorgen kann ist ja in den vergangenen
Tagen auch ein sehr großes
Munitionsdepot entlang dieser
Bahnstrecke zerstört worden und daran
glaube ich zu erkennen dass die Ukraine
sich jetzt gezielt gegen diese Logistik
richtet und wenn die Truppen gegen die
die Ukraine da im Süden gerade kämpft
wenn die weniger Munition haben weniger
Treibstoff haben dann wird
möglicherweise auch der Angriff für die
Ukraine leichter darum scheint es zu
gehen kann man denn jetzt aus diesem
Angriff auch schon den Schluss ziehen
dass die ukrainische gegen Offensive
schon jetzt sozusagen die Rückeroberung
der Krim umfasst oder wäre das noch
verfrüht
den Schuss würde ich daraus jetzt nicht
ziehen ich würde auch generell in
Zweifel ziehen ob denn die Ukraine im
strengen militärischen Sinne die Krim
mit der zurückerobern muss wenn die
Creme abgeschnitten ist von der
Versorgung bei Treibstoff und Munition
dann wird es schon sehr schwer werden
für Russland die Grimm noch zu halten
aber es geht jetzt garantiert um die
Gebiete im Süden und um die Versorgung
dieser Truppen und der russischen Seite
im Süden und das war sehr wirkungsvoller
Schlag was auch eine psychologische
Wirkung wenn die großen diese Brücke
befindet sich in Reichweite der
Langstreckenwaffen der Ukraine
dann sprechen wir generell noch mal über
das Vorankommen der ukrainischen gegen
Offensive Präsident selenski hat ja
eingeräumt dass diese gegen Offensive
langsamer vorangehen würde als von der
ukrainischen Seite ursprünglich
angenommen der premierministerial hat
jetzt gesagt 113 Quadratkilometer sein
zurückerobert etwa acht Ortschaften aber
insgesamt langsamer als gedacht wie
bewerten sie das
es ist langsamer als gedacht aber wenn
sie mal sehen wie lange Russland
gebraucht hat für relativ kleine
jetzt in einer Situation
es geht langsam weil die Kombination aus
bienenfeldern mit sehr großen Flächen
mit ihnen wie sehr tief verlegt worden
sind und gleichzeitig der Gefahr von
Luftangriff zum Beispiel Hubschrauber
die ukrainischen Truppen verlangsamt und
die
ukrainischen Truppen können ja nicht mit
großen hurra einfach darauf losstürmen
sondern sie müssen darauf achten ihre
Truppen zu schützen deswegen geht es
jetzt nur langsam und methodisch und
vorsichtig voran also da wird es jetzt
keine schnellen Durchbrüche geben
sondern wenn dann nur kleine
Fortschritte sie haben die Luft
Überlegenheit der russischen Seite
angesprochen die Russen setzen ja eben
auf Flugzeuge und Hubschrauber ein über
die die Ukraine nicht verfügt welche
Rolle spielt das
Rolle das hat man auch vorhersehen
können bei dieser gegen Offensive man
muss ja leider sagen dass der Terror
sich auszahlt für die russische Seite
denn die luftverteilungssystem mit der
Ukraine werden in den Städten gebraucht
um die Zivilbevölkerung zu schützen
dadurch hat die Ukraine sich natürlich
nicht zur Verfügung um jetzt zum
Beispiel an der Front die eigene Truppen
zu können die Hubschrauber der
russischen Seite können in diesem Gebiet
fliegen auch teilweise die russische
Luftwaffe und leider hat die Ukraine
noch keine F16 mehrzweckkampf Flugzeuge
die diese Hubschrauber bekämpfen und
Abschrecken könnten man kann hoffen dass
diese F 16 Flugzeuge zum Beispiel dass
die jetzt innerhalb der nächsten Monate
kommen und dann würde das auch die Lage
ganz konkrete in Bezug auf diese
Hubschrauber sehr stark verändern die
Russen haben sich außerdem wohl über
längere Zeit auch auf diesen
ukrainischen Vorstoß vorbereitet er war
ja in der Tat auch bei uns schon seit
längerer Zeit erwartet worden viele
Landstriche sie haben es auch
angesprochen für einen Sinn für verdient
was ja ebenfalls das Vorankommen der
Ukraine erschweren dürfte
das ist so gerade diese Minenfelder zum
Teil ja auch mit sehr perfiden Minen die
nicht sofort explodieren sondern sich
zum Beispiel zunächst an die Fahrzeuge
anheften und dann noch einiger Zeit
explodieren
Minenfelder die sehr weitläufig sind in
einem Gebiet in dem man ja sehr weit
schauen kann das ist eine Steppe das ist
sehr flaches Land das heißt wenn sie
dort angreifen kann der Gegner das schon
aus kilometerweise Entfernung sehen das
ist sehr schwierig da voranzukommen dass
die Russen so viel Zeit hatten
Verteidigungsstellungen zu bauen hat ja
auch damit zu tun dass wir viel zu lange
gebraucht haben in Deutschland aber auch
in anderen Partnerländern um zum
Beispiel die Entscheidung zu Lieferung
von schützen und Kampfpanzern zu liefern
natürlich wäre es für die Ukraine
einfacher gewesen diese Gebiete zurück
zu erobern im vergangenen September und
Oktober da haben wir aber nicht das
geliefert was dafür notwendig war
insofern sollten wir jetzt auch nicht
unsere überwunden dass es jetzt
schwieriger geht als das vielleicht von
einigen erwartet war ich glaube das auch
niemand in den westlichen Streitkräften
ganz besonders nicht in der Bundeswehr
Erfahrung hat mit dem was die Ukraine da
machen deswegen sollten wir uns auch mit
Beurteilung oder mit Ratschlägen glaube
ich da etwas zurückhalten generell gibt
es den militärischen Grundsatz das
offensiven vor allem dann erfolgreich
sind wenn sie gleich in den ersten Tagen
durchschlagen das wäre jetzt eher ein
schlechtes Zeichen für die Ukraine
man kann sich die Frage stellen
inwiefern in diesem Krieg denn
militärische Grundsätze in der
uneingeschränkten Form ihre Geltung
haben
vieles von dem was
Militärexperten für Russland für möglich
gehalten haben ist ja überhaupt nicht
eingetreten der Krieg hat sich völlig
anders entwickelt dass die Ukraine jetzt
in den ersten Tagen keinen Erfolg hatte
ist sicherlich besonders für die Ukraine
bedauerlich aber das war nun mal
einkalkuliert haben so wie man auch eine
mögliche Sprengung des Staudamms durch
Russland einkalkuliert hat hatte
seine Pläne umsetzen wir haben die
Hauptkräfte der ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive noch überhaupt nicht
gesehen wir sehen erste Angriffe aber
wir wissen noch gar nicht wo der
Hauptstoß erfolgen wird insofern sind
auch Überraschungen noch möglich ja das
ist auch ein ganz interessanter Punkt
denn in der Tat also alles was man hört
und liest Leute darauf hin dass die
Ukraine bislang nur einen relativ
kleinen Teil der zur Verfügung stehenden
Kräfte einsetzt welches Kalkül könnte
dahinter stecken
es ist ein bisschen die Vorgehensweise
man klopft mal auf den Busch und schaut
wo die Vögelchen aufsteigen also die
Ukrainer greifen an und schauen dann wie
reagieren die Russen wo ist die
russische Artillerie wo sind die
Hubschrauber wo sind diese
minenverlegegeräte um dann im in der
nächsten Welle erstmal die Artillerie
das hat man ja in den letzten Tagen
gesehen gezielt auszuschalten
möglicherweise an die Hubschrauber
abzuschießen die Minen verlegegeräte zu
bekämpfen damit dann in einem nächsten
Angriff der Widerstand etwas geringer
ausfällt sowas geht natürlich nicht
schnell und erzeugt keine schnellen
Durchbrüche kann aber sehr wirkungsvoll
sein und die Ukraine wird ihre
Hauptkräfte in der Reserve behalten bis
zum Beispiel die Minenfelder stärker
geräumt sind bis es größere
Möglichkeiten gibt auch richtige
Durchbrüche zu erzielen denn
entscheidende Punkt ist ja gar nicht der
Durchbruch den muss man erreichen aber
entscheidend ist ja dann wie viel Kräfte
hat man dann in der Reserve um aus dem
Durchbruch etwas zu machen und viele
Gebiete wieder zurück zu erobern wenn
ich richtig verstehe dann verhält sich
aber auch die russische Seite nicht nur
passiv im Moment etwas zu lässt sich
über russische offensive oder Gegenstöße
sagen
russland hat sich vorbereitet offenbar
auch mental auf diese Gegenoffensive und
man muss einfach ganz nüchtern
festhalten die russischen
Verteidigungslinien lassen jetzt bisher
keine Anzeichen von Panik erkennen und
vor allen Dingen gehen die Russen sehr
sehr früh zugegen Angriffen über wir
versuchen also ein tiefes Eindringen der
Ukrainer in Richtung der verschiedenen
verteilungslinien von vornherein zu
vermeiden weil das Dilemma für Russland
ist wenn die Ukraine erstmal ein Stück
weiter in dieses Gebiet vordringt dann
muss Russland entweder Reserven dorthin
bringen oder einen Durchbruch zu lassen
und trotzdem versucht mit frühen
Gegenangriffen jetzt diese Dinge zu
vermeiden
Entlastungsangriffe der russischen Seite
besonders im Osten im Gebiet le man gab
es die ja vor einigen Tagen sind aber
gescheitert sind von den Ukrainern
abgewehrt worden wir hören gerade im
Hintergrund bei Ihnen eine Lautsprecher
Durchsage sie sind am Flughafen in
London das vielleicht noch mal zu
Erklärung für unsere Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer ja abschließend vielleicht
noch mal die Frage lassen jetzt die
Ereignisse der letzten Tage irgendwelche
Rückschlüsse zu auf den weiteren Verlauf
in den nächsten Tagen oder Wochen
das heißt den Rückschluss zu dass die
Ukraine sich auf ein langsames
systematisches methodisches Vorgehen
jetzt festgelegt hat und dass die
Ukraine wieder auf ihre stärkste Waffe
setzt die Bekämpfung der russischen
Logistik das hat schon mehrfach zum
Erfolg geführt und das ist ja auch der
Hintergrund warum wir heute über diese
Brücke sprechen und über eisenbahndepots
andere Dinge Munition und Treibstoff
die Ukraine braucht dafür dass weiter
tun zu können langfristige systematische
Unterstützung und das sollten wir bei
der Beobachtung der Lage nicht vergessen
also wir sind jetzt nicht diejenigen die
hier nur zuschauen und abwarten sondern
wir müssen weiter langfristig und
systematisch unterstützen auch mit
Unterstützung der Industrie wenn die
Ukraine in der Luftverteidigung
insgesamt besser wird dann hilft das
auch den Truppen an der Front
wir haben viele Dinge spät geliefert und
wir sollten auch nicht so überzogene
Erwartungshaltung haben so nach dem
Motto oh jetzt habt ihr doch unsere
Leopard kam von der warum fahrt ihr denn
jetzt nicht einfach durch die Linien
durch und gewinnt den Krieg also wir
müssen die militärischen Realitäten
anerkennen ich habe den Eindruck dass
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte jetzt
ruhig und systematisch ihren
militärischen Plan umsetzen und bin
optimistisch dass der Ukraine ist
gelingen wird auf diese Weise einen
Durchbruch zu erreichen die
Einschätzungen des militär-experten Nico
lange vielen Dank für das Gespräch